everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse today we're gonna keep working on
that Salesforce form that's it's got a
lot of a different stuff going on so
it's in Salesforce but it's built by a
company called Target X that was
actually customized by a company called
Jenzabar and really it was built with a
combination of these visualforce apex
components and angular so we got a lot
going on here but today it's not that
complicated because we're basically just
doing CSS so we're gonna style this
thing with CSS just an update on some of
the other projects I have a new issue
open in the react bulletin and I know
the reactive Resource Center project
because the head of my department uses
Safari 9.1 on a Mac and the forms don't
work so I did a little bit of research
on it and some testing and I put some
info on that issue so if anybody really
likes trying to get older browsers to
work with things then have at it
otherwise I'm just going to keep working
on it this week on our bulletin projects
or react bulletin I've merged in two new
pool requests so maybe we can go over
those a little bit later on during the
question and answer session if we have
time I do have a meeting at 3:00 p.m. my
time eastern time so that gives us an
hour and a half till my meeting I would
like to finish up in around an hour if
possible to give me time to prep for my
meeting but the meetings only about 20
feet away from where I'm sitting right
now so it shouldn't take me that long to
get there so if we go over at our 15
minutes that's fine too but
sebastien and Harsha both submitted
amazing pool requests so hopefully we
have time to go over those otherwise you
can check it out third thing I want to
mention before we get started is that
October fest is almost over so if you
don't know what hack tober fest is let
me just put this up briefly so you can
check out
Oktoberfest digitalocean comm you get a
free t-shirt if you sign up and then
submit for pool requests before October
31st is over so I think you have today
and tomorrow so check that out if you
haven't already and if you haven't got
your 4 and yet like me then check out
some of the repos that we've been
working on their stores some issues open
and if you find something that I missed
that needs work feel free to submit a
pull request for that as well what I'd
like to ask all of you is to let me know
if there's something on one of your
projects that you'd like for me to work
on if there's something let me know
either in the live chat or on Twitter or
email or whatever social media you like
if you can find my phone number you can
call leave a message if you want but I
just need to know the URL of your
repository and what issue you you want
me to fix so I've been looking for some
good issues to use as my my fourth and
final Oktoberfest pull request but I
thought earlier today when I was looking
through the list I thought you know what
I would really much rather work on an
issue that that you all need some help
with since you all helped me so much
with my projects I thought that would be
cool so at least I want to give you all
first dibs on my last PR and if I don't
hear from any of you then I'll probably
work on something tomorrow I will not be
streaming tomorrow
my wife has some testing that she needs
to have done for some some health issues
in the morning and so I'll be out all
morning and I thought I don't really
want to get ready and come into
for a few hours in the afternoon if I
could just work from home unfortunately
as some of you already know my internet
is not good enough at home to do a
decent quality stream so I'll be off
tomorrow so for those of you do be cell
awaiting celebrating Halloween happy
Halloween and I will be back Wednesday
most likely unless something happens all
right so enough enough with getting all
of that out of the way okay not bad I
only spent five minutes with the intro
here so I've done worse all right so
let's check out our Trello board first
just to see what we were working on so
for now we want to fix those button
colors if you remember last week's
stream the last stream on on Friday
we're working with some weird things
that were overriding our styles for our
buttons and we tested out a few ways to
make our styles override the the other
styles that are in there and couldn't
figure it out and I had said that I was
going to try to look around and see if I
could find something in Salesforce I
ended up not having time to because the
head of my department called me in to
check out her computer because she
couldn't submit anything through our
Resource Center that we had launched
last month at some point so I spent the
rest of my day here trying to figure out
what was wrong and then researching bugs
for Safari 9 point I think it's nine
point one so anyway I was not able to do
what I wanted to do so I'm thinking for
this string we may just have to resort
to throwing in some importance and later
on if I'm digging around in some files
and I figure out where I can remove some
of the styles that are currently being
injected in there somewhere then we can
always remove them
later but if you'll notice there's two
things we need to change just to in case
you you weren't with us last week this
blue shot this is actually a shadow
underneath so we need our shadow to
override that and then I do not want
this button to transform like that and
get shorter and wider other than that
the button is not looking too bad so
that's what we're going to work on first
and then I think we'll probably switch
over here to this side nap and we'll get
this styled a little bit differently
than it is now it's going to fit the
university styles and we'll try to make
it match as much as possible some of the
the other side drawer side knives that
we've been doing for our other sites all
right so let's get to it let me move my
timer somewhere up here let me put it up
here now weights far away's I can get
from my my face in the corner I won't
cover it up like I normally do so I was
doing a Pomodoro session before on
another project so I'm just gonna
restart that now and let's get over here
to find our code
I want to rearrange this order here
there we go okay great so here's our app
template we were putting our CSS in a
separate file but I've given up on that
it just added an extra step to the flow
so I could always at some point just
copy this style tag over into this file
if I think it's useful so let me see I
should have watched the last part of the
stream on Friday I didn't have time and
think about it to remind me of what we
were editing I'm I'm pretty sure it
wasn't that it would have been button
styles which is down here
there we go okay so we're already using
important on the color let's try let's
see alright let me see what's going on
here with this transform first of all I
want to see how they're doing this so
that we can properly override it so
which one this is the button correct
it's interesting all right so we're
gonna move this all the way over so that
we can see our dev tools and our our
button here okay yeah so that's what we
want you want this one let's see what
changes interesting all right so let's
see
trying to see any type of change
happening here we could maybe check oops
check the computed maybe we'll see it
better there okay see nothing there
let's yeah interesting okay
with
hmm
I this is kind of odd I would kind of
expect to see something changing right
let's see
and it since you seen
so I just heard something beep on my
computer I wanted to see what message I
was getting do you ever have too many
messenger things open at once and you
you're not sure which one you're getting
a message on that's that's how it is for
me right now all right actually I
haven't even checked the live chat at
all yet let me let me check this and see
if anyone has any ideas let me see
okay I don't see anything yet also if
you're new the way I do things is I wait
until this 25 minute timer is up and
then I go to the live chat and answer
all your questions so please don't feel
bad if I don't see or answer your
question right away I will answer it on
our question answer breaks or at the end
of the stream I I stopped coding and I
just go through the live chat and answer
questions alright let's find out what
this this is like the I think I
mentioned last week I feel like a
detective when I'm searching through
some foreign CSS or this potentially
could be some JavaScript stuff going on
too but just searching through dev tools
trying to figure out what's going on and
how to how to change it that's that's a
lot of what ends up happening when when
I'm editing somebody else's stuff
yes
okay
all right it's got to be this one I mean
this has all the other styles
there we go okay now I'm seeing
something different well I don't know
how I missed that before but uh here we
have some hover some hover styles are
those are styles and some of them yeah
those are our styles let's see these are
the styles that we're trying to override
she's gotta be another hover style
these are our styles again
so the width isn't even you see in dev
tools if you see a kind of grayed out a
little bit then that's that's not
directly getting the width from anything
any styles on this particular component
transitions
it's not taking our border-radius too
well let's do what we know we need to do
we need to get that border-radius
working in particular on this isn't even
hover style let's go ahead and put it
throw it important on that water radius
and
and see what else we need we can check
let's take this hover off for a second
just to see what else is being
overwritten these are ours
okay
we could put important on our box shadow
and
just what I'm let's actually let's see
how this looks now probably auto logged
out of this yep I am okay to login login
on another screen logs me out it's
pretty fast log out for Salesforce I
don't know if that's by default or if
the admins for for my University set it
like that
[Applause]
just what we were working on no it
wasn't that
hmm all right I'm gonna have to go in
and find I see it there it is
all right so if you haven't seen us
working on this the last three three
streams this is not an ideal workflow of
having to copy and paste things over but
since I'm working in Salesforce this is
what I have to work with right now I'm
not aware of a different way to do it if
there were some other way to integrate
this better with my normal workflow I
definitely would do that and fresh
what's whoops forget a sign in here no I
don't okay
let's let me grab my password from the
browser while I'm actually logged into
my LastPass
sorry about this I should have refreshed
everything beforehand and got logged in
oh okay not bad we still have that weird
thing going on but at least we've taken
care of everything else all right we
just have to figure this up okay so
let's see try turning off padding and
hover say all right so we have some
ideas here in the live chat about what
to do let me read through these
okay so John Hanson says some of the
styles that are giving you problems may
stem from higher up the Dom okay yeah I
thought that but I didn't really check
that much higher so I will double check
that hard says check the padding
okay cool I will check that and John
says if the buttons inside a flex div
its width will get determined by its
alignment flex start okay let's let me
check the padding first cuz I think
that'll be the easiest thing to do since
we're already on this component so let
me go to computed and just see what
padding we have 15 all around and now
let's let's hover and let's check out
the padding now oh yeah we have a
different padding for sure okay cool
let's switch it up bill 15 all around no
matter what and see if that fixes it
yep that looks good okay cool so we
should be able to just set our padding
hello I see I see what's happening it
looks like our padding was being
overridden on here but not when we did a
hover okay that makes sense because when
the the default CSS probably just put
padding on the the button styles and
then didn't bother putting it on the
hover styles which you wouldn't normally
do that that makes sense okay so this
should fix it let's double check it and
then we can move on to the next thing
No all right we still have something
else going on so it's no longer the
padding because you see it's not it's
not changing shape so we've solved one
thing now is its line hide font size
something like that let's see whoops
however alright let's see make sure this
is actually triggering it yep there we
go alright so let's check our hover yeah
let's check our computers who we have
going on here trans okay so we have a
text transform which should be fine
because I think we are already doing
that text size adjust where are we
getting that from
that's weird
let's actually look to the font look
bigger I think it does I think it might
be the font size let me go back here and
check our font size so we have font
weights line Heights and font size that
could probably all be okay so we have 14
here and that's not hovered I think
hovered I think it was 16 right font 16
yeah alright so it looks like our font
size is going from 14 to 16 I would like
it to be 16 no matter what so let's add
an important ear and this is the same
thing that was happening with the
padding right so the default styles have
font size 14
so that was overriding our 16 but then
it's hover state did not have a font
size at all
so our 16 was actually working so this
should now work
I thought earlier that the font-size
looked different but it was hard to tell
with all the other things changing there
we go perfect okay all right so check
that out we've got a slight hover effect
which I like much better than that
what was happening before we're having
just a huge change although now that I
think about it it may not have had that
large change by default we might have
inadvertently caused that hover effect
to happen by some of the styles that we
had applied earlier before we even on
this page so I think that that's that
was probably the case all right let's
get rid of this hover as well while
we're here that's a hover we want to get
rid of that color and the text
decoration I think we already have a
hover here yep
so let's just put it in portent for
these I want to give my disclaimer on
using important so you've probably heard
this before but just in case you don't
normally want to use important if you're
writing your own CSS for a project from
scratch
don't use important right because you
have complete control you can just
change how you have things set up and
either through adding classes or
changing the order in your CSS you
should you should be able to make things
work just through specificity and then
keep everything cascading once you had
important it breaks the Cascade so it
doesn't matter like right now this is
just an a right it's not specific at all
I mean I guess we have an a:hover in
here right but somebody can make this
super specific and put like HTML body
div
and it would still be overridden by this
because we put important there
so you see how it breaks somebody could
put inline Styles on a specific a zag
and it would still be broken and and
overridden by this important so we're
only using it in this case because we
don't have access or control of much of
what's going on in terms of the mark-up
and what's going on in terms of the
other styles that are being added to the
page in various places so in this case
we're stuck with important is one of our
last options and that's what it should
always be a last option all right I'm
not even going to test that because
that's very simple it should definitely
work now let me check how much time we
have okay so it's almost up for that
session let's add in that extra Pomodoro
session and Mark that is done and let's
go inside of let's just go ahead and or
next time one we'll do it we'll change
the colors and as a part of that we'll
probably do these together we're gonna
change the indicator colors as well okay
I'll be able to pull this over goodness
I've got really what um wait how did we
get it did we get logged out again it's
possible I accidentally hit sign out
when I was
mousing over it okay let me grab my
password again
okay all right so we're logged in again
and all we need to see now is the
sidebar and my sessions almost up so I'm
just gonna go ahead and break now do
five minutes in the live chat so I'll be
starting at the top and just working my
way down answering as many questions as
I can
that's
okay horseshit asked if I'd seen PR 54
which by now I've already said it I have
seen its merch now
Arshad says I saw an inspirational for
loop so if if y'all can see this in the
live chat will probably make more sense
but for age equals 0
a when age is greater than or if age is
greater than or equal to life dot length
knowledge plus plus that's cool I like
that
okay so John Hanson says please
implement styled components you will
save yourself a lot of grief you can use
an imported theme as a wrapper and still
be able to cleanly style components as
standalone components okay yeah and hard
shipments and styled components are
specific to react yeah so I mean
obviously we can't use them with
Salesforce but we can start using them
on our other react projects
okay haha Irish it says that button took
a long time to debug yes it did John
Hanson says I usually shed it's here if
I'm forced to use important yeah it
feels a little bit like giving up like
oh yeah yeah there's got to be a better
way but I just don't want to do it so
let's just put important in there yeah I
I find myself using important a lot less
than I used to today I probably used an
important so far in the half hour we've
been streaming I've used important more
than I've probably used it in the last
month or two I it depends on the project
though if it's something like this where
I have to deal with already existing
code I tend to use it a lot more alright
all right I think I actually there's not
that much in the live chat so I think
I've gotten to the bottom of it so
that's cool so I shouldn't go over my
time here Harshit says she checked NXT
shared CEO Diane her was that the
one that you built the chat thing yeah
okay
cool yeah I definitely check that out
that is really cool so if you haven't
already checked it out harsh I built
this really cool chat site and it's NXT
share dot Co dot I n so yeah it was
really cool I checked that out Friday
that's Friday yeah I was really
impressed by that all right well since
I'm out of stuff on the live chat I may
as well start the next next session so
yeah let's get started on this so if you
ask anything after this point I will get
through it after this next session this
will be our last code session and then
we'll just do all question-and-answer
and I got a question in there right at
the end says how's the weather today
it's a little bit cold and rainy where
I'm at it's about 40 degrees it was in
the upper 30s this morning but I think
it's in the mid 40s now and it's it's
rainy so it's appropriate weather for
this time of year all right
I actually don't mind that 40s or 50s
and rain I think it's kind of nice I'm
not sure why but boys I've always liked
it when it's dark outside and about 50
degrees and slightly raining I don't
know if I would say it's my favorite but
it's pretty close to it okay
I'm just playing around a little bit
just to think about what colors I want
here we will probably end up going with
a lot of white like we normally do now
I'm thinking about how far I want to
take this now let's let's see first
we'll stick with the colors but just to
let you know what I'm thinking right now
I'm wondering how far could we change
this to look like what we normally do I
I do kind of like that it has this year
that's that that's not bad that's a nice
indicator so I don't want to change that
but whenever it is actually open I think
it might be nicer if it did look closer
to what we normally do well we'll see
once we get in here and see some of the
markup it'll be pretty obvious how
difficult it would be to try to make
this look exactly like our other side
now sir as close as possible oops and
actually we forgot to change this color
too did was that on another one change
I'll change the icon colors as another
another to do so I wondered why I didn't
didn't do that one all right so let's
change the background color first and
we'll have to change the font color as
well because we won't be able to read
anything so let's go up so we get the
container div where the color supplied
there we go
yep that's where the colors applied so
let's switch that up all right let's go
with white and let's see I'm gonna make
this whoops black wanna make that I'm
gonna have to go down lower okay
well at first we can at least put this
background color on target apps next
application sidebar this for really
change when not expand it yeah we want
to put it on that base style so it
applies to both forms of the sidebar
okay
so si bar let's put this below the nav
bar and put it right in here and sidebar
and
okay
and then let's see where the colors up
being applied color
that's weird
to share it again
oh okay inherit all right and see that's
the first time okay on so we're gonna
have to do an h1 and then let's go down
to the vowels and then a okay h2 why
well would you have an h2 inside of an a
tag inside of an li anyway I can
I kind of see what they're doing here
but really it wouldn't it be better to
just leave the headers as this and not
have them repeated as H tags I gotta
check this now because if these aren't H
tags then I'm gonna be upset okay at
least they are H tags okay so I have
enough to do this where we add sidebar
okay so let's go target X application
sidebar oops
and we want to get the H ones and then
sidebar h2s and the color
let me grab me grab our dark color from
somewhere else
hmm
I don't see it let's just make it
I'm always I never want to type out the
rgba colors by my myself I just I always
want to do it like this I don't know why
a father would have been faster in that
case you just type it out myself
all right now let's put this here
and I do want to see what this looks
like before we go on
okay well some of what we did worked and
some did not so we may just have to put
important on that and move on
let's check it out for a second
yeah yeah same same reason it was being
overridden with our button styles so oh
they're okay we actually need to change
the font as well so it's good to know
all right so let's add and pour it here
and let's go up and grab our font
and
actually let's try to do it important up
here I don't think there's anywhere
where we wouldn't want to use this font
so John Hanson I just saw your your
comment had the little devil emoji with
important oh there we go
all right yeah it works okay
well not for everything so our h1 it did
not work
that's wait a second
display:none
why do we have
oh this is weird
our button color is now not working
all right let's move this button color
back to testing and we'll look at that
in a little bit but right now this is
what we're working on
so in each one
did we not have text there am i looking
at the wrong element maybe I'm looking
the wrong thing I am sorry about that I
was looking at the wrong place
okay and this is not an h1 it's a span
so let's change this first of all let's
make sure they're not setting the color
they are okay but they're setting it on
this so we should be fine to put that
here and these are yeah let's go ahead
and just do both of these now actually
we're not gonna you're not gonna want to
do them together we want them to be
different colors but I'll just copy them
copy the classes over okay
uh I didn't copy okay let's try this
again I'll get the right stuff
yeah and let's see
let's try to nest this
and see if we can override things
through nesting well it's not really
necessary I'm thinking in sass terms
like normally I would nest this is
that's not really what you would say and
CSS alright so for this we're gonna go
with that green color that Franciscan
University green and for this one we'll
use this same color that we have up here
which actually if we're going to do that
we should just do it here okay
really we're gonna have to use important
oh that's why background-color sector
certification
background-color
that's why and then for this that's just
putting Fortin here
I'm not sure how many more videos we'll
have on this I I wanted to do enough
videos to be able to make a playlist out
of this that would be reasonable so
we're at four videos for this this may
be the last one I may do one more I
don't really want to spend a ton of time
I haven't really been getting a lot of
views for this kind of thing so I just
don't think there's that many people
that are interested and this kind of
stuff I think there's more interest in
the react stuff that we've been doing so
I'd like to switch back I didn't really
want to just stop right in the middle of
it I'd like to get it to some point of
completion before we stop that's okay
not bad I mean color wise it's that we
can at least see everything now I really
don't know about this this change here I
mean I don't I don't mind this crossing
to make it an X but I don't really like
this size change so I think I want to
get rid of that so let me add that as
another to do that falls outside of our
scope of changing colors
is it a hover effect as an AFF ECT or a
hover effect like EF Fe CT I can never
remember I always ask my wife because
she's an English teacher and she
actually teaches English at the college
that I work at and she always knows okay
and we've changed the colors for the
side nav I guess the one thing we could
change the colors of these dividers do
we want actually a masseuse do we even
want to have those dividers there
anymore is that necessary we don't
normally do dividers between every menu
item do we like let's check we don't
want to hear no we don't we have them
between different you know categories of
not in this sense but like different
sections of our menu but this isn't
necessarily a different section these
these all play the same role you know
for now I'm not gonna do anything with
them what I probably wouldn't add is you
know this this hover behind let's do
that let's let's add a hover behind now
this is where it might get a little
weird are we even going to be able to do
that same hover because you know where
did where is this extent oh actually we
need a we need a shadow on this as well
this looks really weird so we need a
shadow and we can we can definitely
shorten this there's no reason that it
has to be that long so let's add these
and we're going to
okay
and let me
we want to change this color
there we go I like that better
and
yeah let me we do have shadows on here
correct no we don't we know we don't
have a shadow let's let's find one where
we we bring that out so okay all right
so maybe we don't have a shadow normally
but it just graze everything out so we
have this overlay
but in this case we don't really want
the overlay right because you can I
don't know it does automatically close
okay well then we probably should add an
overlay this will do what will either
hover or overlay I don't want to do the
border because you can see we really
only do the border if we have it fixed
let's let's shrink this up don't see
what we actually have on
yeah we don't have the border or at
least it's not obvious but that there is
a border there yeah so let's let's keep
stick with that and so that's what we'll
do so we'll either do an overlay or a
shadow
actually you know what we're gonna add a
shadow' no matter what because when it's
no I'm gonna do that
hey we got back to that screen I don't
know if you remember but I think of the
first day we worked on this we got to
this screen and it looked terrible and I
didn't I couldn't figure out how to get
back to it okay that's cool well now we
know how to get back to it I just have
to hit this button
okay so we'll need something here maybe
here this would be a good place to have
a border
I may have to think about this so we're
gonna add maybe add the shadow here I'll
just add some notes maybe an overlay
we're closed okay all right so I have to
mess around with a couple of these
couple options that we have here and
that's about it for this
so let's um let's see colors yeah so
we've we've changed the colors I think
we're safe to mark that off where we
don't really need to do anything else
with colors for the side now and yep all
right not bad so we only got two to do
stun but we came in well with the
exception in this one where it took
twice as long as we thought the colors
were right on target in terms of time so
not bad
I may have to just end up by default
putting important on everything because
it seems like no matter how much I try
to not have to use important I have to
use it on almost every element so our
new strategy might just be use important
oh man and I just got a message on slack
that there is food in the kitchen
free food so I definitely have to end
this before my meeting so that I can
stop in and get free food I have one of
my co-workers always lets me know if
there's free food so I joke with her and
say that's actually in a job description
that she has to do that but I appreciate
it she knows how much I enjoy free food
that's kind of pretty much the the one
benefit I can see the coming into work
instead of working from home that I
would miss it's getting the free food
that is frequently here at work okay let
me scroll up and now at this point I'm
gonna do Question and Answer so if you
have any questions please put them in
the live chat now even if you don't have
a question appreciate it if you if you
can if you'd stick around and help
answer some of the questions because I
certainly don't have all the answers to
everything and I appreciate having
different opinions on things as well but
if you got to take off thanks for
watching I should be back on Wednesday
and I will not be back tomorrow but if
you need to send me a message or
something on social media or whatever
I'll I'll be online I'll just be working
from home
okay let's trying to find where I left
off okay
sciences go bucs yeah
oh okay harsh it says will you be
running post CSS autoprefixer at the end
of your CSS that's a great idea
I actually I really like to run that but
normally I have it set up to run
automatically and in this case we don't
have any type of build tools running so
I probably would have forgot about that
if you hadn't mentioned it so thank you
so let's autoprefixer awesome thank you
Harshit that is a wonderful idea okay
John says I think most builds include
post CSS though when you do dev tools in
the browser much of what is added gets
crossed out anyhow yeah let's see Anna
says what's the hardest you've ever
worth I think maybe I'll give two
answers from that one will be code
related and one non code related so I
worked well actually some of you all may
remember when it was right around the
time to launch the catechetical
Institute website which was project one
that we worked on I worked some crazy
hours for at least the last two weeks of
that project I worked almost double my
normal amount of hours so we're talking
like 70 to 80 hours a week that was
pretty crazy
I think I worked for like 14 hours one
day that was wild I think I streamed for
five hours one day I think I streamed
and then took a break and it streamed
again so that was pretty crazy I have
done I've done like and where I've
worked pretty much all day and then as
late as I could stay up at night went to
sleep for couple hours woke up again and
started working
on a project so in terms of code that's
the hardest just trying to put out as
much code as I possibly can and stay up
as late as I can but in terms of in
general how what's the hardest I've ever
worked I don't know I've had some jobs
that were that were tough physically I
used to work for for a city in West
Virginia called Weirton so I worked for
the city of Wooten which that's the city
I grew up in and I did that for about
six years but it was on it was seasonal
so I didn't always they didn't have
enough for me to do during the
wintertime usually but that job was a
lot of like eight hours a day pushing a
lawn mower doing maintenance work
generally like lifting things working on
whatever needed fixed whatever needed
cleaned so like that was somewhat
physically demanding is like you're just
on your feet every day that matter how
hot it is how cold it is like you're
working so but I was young I mean this
was when I was a teenager and so it it
wasn't that bad then I think back to it
now I think man I'd be sore if I tried
to do that now that was tough and I'll
tell you what I used to be a manager an
assistant manager at a Burger King
restaurant it's a fast-food restaurant
that was really tough because that would
work these shifts and sometimes I'd work
ten hours straight and we'd be so busy
that I just couldn't stop like I
literally could not take a minute break
because we always had people in there
and we are always understaffed so I
couldn't just manage it was like you're
making sandwiches you got a headset on
you're taking orders you're running the
cash register all at the same time that
you're trying to make sure everybody
else was doing their job that was wild
that was just like exhausting
and you work a shift like that and close
up and like on the weekend you'd close
up at 2:00 a.m. during the week you
close up at midnight and then if you
work the next shift the next stiff shift
started at 4:00 a.m. so you couldn't get
full amount of sleep so anyway I'm sure
y'all don't care about how to manage a
fast-food restaurant but that was that
was really wild just in terms of like
working that much without a break all
right let's see how cool John Hanson
said time for dictionary.com to see how
that affects or affects things okay John
says the the hover behind sounds good so
we're talking about on a hover behind
these items I'd also add a shadow' to
help define its needed for the Seidman
yeah it's definitely needed now that
it's the same color I mean I could see
why they didn't have it before
it wasn't exactly necessary the shadow
could just show when the side I was out
yeah that's true I mean really I guess
when you think about like in terms of
material design of everything's on like
a different level the side nav is
actually on a higher level unless I'm
remembering this wrong the side nav is
on a higher level than the the paper
like the you know the normal level so be
like Niazi zero right if we're thinking
z-index so it would make sense that
there would be a shadow no matter what
since since we have the partially open
state and the open fully open state we
don't really have a closed state so if
there should be a shadow yeah okay we
have this sub I guess we can keep this
sub header here
I'm not a huge fan because you all know
I don't really like thick headers and
this makes it really thick but yeah I
mean this side nav realistically should
probably be at the same level I'm gonna
have to double-check the material design
Docs to make sure that the app bar which
is what this is called in the in the
docs and the side drawer
I think it's called side drawer are
supposed to be at the same level of the
z-index level so I shouldn't say see
index I don't want you to get confused
with CSSA index I mean that the Z height
level surface was XYZ coordinates right
we have our x and y coordinate is it is
X this way yeah I think X Y trying to
remember back to high school math class
and then your Z coordinate would be like
depth right or height however you want
to think about it so that's what I'm
talking about
oh cool innocence thanks for the stream
you're welcome thank you so much for
watching and for asking questions in the
in the live chat I appreciate it alright
John Hansen says react equals mystery I
figured how this array dot fine and
change state to the array but to use the
new array as a parameter and then using
this state state dot arrayed key value
is confusing that sounds confusing
reading it I probably I'd have to think
about that you see the code to
understand really understand that there
are some weird confusing things about
react I really like react but I've
definitely been confused at times and
thought what why isn't this working
so
usually whenever it finally works it
makes sense why it works and why it
didn't work the other way but getting to
that point of realizing what the right
way to do it is is can be a challenge
sometimes luckily I have you all to let
me know and it usually doesn't take that
long when when you're watching to let me
know what the right way is but it can
definitely take a while sometimes let's
see
Rohini says hello from India hey how's
it going thanks for watching from India
I know it's late what is it
well 45 right in the morning right now
or at night however you want to think
about it John answer says it works and
it is logical to react but Wow yeah yeah
that's what what is this angle I seen
this on different social media but it's
stuff like react makes complicated
things simple and simple things
complicated some something like that
yeah but that's I would agree with that
statement right there's just there's
some things that I used to do with
jQuery you know back when back a year
ago when I used to be into jQuery
I don't wanna don't to make it sound
like it's been that long time but you do
so much a query it would be the simplest
thing in the world just so easy and then
with react it's like how can I do this
exact same thing and it seems so much
more complex but some things are really
easy with reactant and I remember that
them being just super difficult with
jQuery and I just had all the spaghetti
code when I tried to do it so for me at
least the the transition from jQuery
based stuff to react stuff has had more
benefits than drawbacks it definitely
took me longer to build the same fun
action ality when I first started but I
think now I'm at the level where I
faster with reacts not only that but
everything's more reliable with react
and I think it's a heck of a lot easier
to other people for other people to read
the code and contribute to it
I still like dread going back to some of
my old applications that I built with
with jQuery so like we've read on it
like the Resource Center that we redid
in react I'm so glad that I never have
to go back to the original and look at
it again
I didn't delete the code it's it's still
on git and github as a private room
faucet honey I'll probably never make it
public but anyway and then now the
bulletin that we're working on when that
finally launches then the I won't have
to look back at the other code and that
will the jQuery version will also remain
a Friday treat actually I don't really
care if you all would look at that if
you really wanted to I make it public
but the only thing I'm worried about is
making sure I don't have any any keys or
anything that I shouldn't have in there
because since it was a private repo I
never bothered removing any keys so I'd
have to double check on that okay John
says it sounds LOL sounds like my
thoughts on jquery yes it's a different
hat one has to wear even from JavaScript
yeah for sure
alright John says love to see it alright
cool
I'll have to yeah I'll see about making
it public I'm pretty sure the Resource
Center one I can make public I think the
only like keys that I had was the I was
storing data in Google sheets so I had
like the URL to store things in a Google
sheet but I'm no longer using those
sheets so I can just
shut it off so that you can't use that
anymore and that that should be fine
the the bullets in one we'll see yeah
aha
I may have to do some things before I
can make the bullets in one public we
may have to may I be after I launch the
newer version of it the react version
but I'm pretty sure I could also make
that public as well so so you can see it
it might off to double-check everything
but I'm pretty sure I will be able to
make in public all right almost to the
bottom of the live shot here Blake says
I'm working on like three projects what
do I do I want to do them all at the
same time well I'm kind of in the same
situation right now so I have this
project we're still working on the
bulletin and I'm trying to sort out some
bugs on the Resource Center I just
finished up that react native projects
for the Udacity nano degree which I'm
still going to make that video for the
nanodegree I have not forgotten about
that so yeah so anyway when I have lots
of projects to do I make sure that I
take notes so I don't get confused and I
do i do Trello boards and I make sure I
write down notes on the cards so I can
jump back and forth I have a lot more
windows open on my on my computer when
it's like that but it's definitely
doable it also helps if the projects are
somewhat related then it's nice because
you can use what you learn on one
project on the other project it's kind
of like like when I was in college it
was nice when I took classes that
overlapped in content so that you've
already learned it in one class and then
maybe a few weeks later you're tested on
it in another class and so it's like you
don't really have to spend as much work
because
because you took the classes at the same
time you're learning the same material
and it cuts down on the amount of time
you have to study projects are the same
if you can do similar projects at the
same time you can just recycle code from
one project to another and complete both
of the projects faster than it would
take you if you only did one so it can
work it can definitely be more
beneficial to work on multiple things at
once it just depends on what projects
they are
oh cool so Rohini says visiting this
channel after three months dude super
cool series of tutorials from free code
camp excellent job guys
mission target front-end JavaScript and
design Jessie will watch all your
tutorials ah
that's that's awesome that's really
awesome I'm glad you glad you like it I
think we've come a long way in the last
in the last three months I think
I certainly have come a long way with
with all of your help in my
understanding of react and I think maybe
it like into my skills as a live
streamer
I don't know you all let me know but I
feel like I'm able to better balance
questions in code now for a while there
I would get off track way too easily
and I feel sorry for everybody that was
watching those earlier streams but I
think we got a decent system now and it
seems seems to be working I get less
complaints that I talk too much now I
use I used to get comments on the videos
and in the live chat like stop talking
more code which I thought was funny and
I agreed with okay and after saying that
it really is time for me to stop talking
because I have six minutes before my
meeting starts so let me hurry up and
see the last few things that were in
here to see Jessie please upload
previous tutorials on github trying to
think I think everything that we've done
in the videos is on github so some of
the stuff that I'll upload stuff that
I've done but I haven't done videos on
it so you can certainly check it out and
ask me questions about it if you want
but some of my earlier stuff will be
better examples of what not to do and
what to do because we've since you know
learn better ways to do it or at least
I've learned better ways to do it so
but I still will put them up there as
well I'm not I'm not embarrassed by it
because it's my old work everybody has
their old work that they can improve one
so let's see all right so thank you so
much for joining me
I'll be back like I said Wednesday not
tomorrow so have a happy Halloween
tomorrow and also let me know if anybody
has any issues on github or once we do
submit a pull request let me know
because I need to submit one before the
end of the day tomorrow
so I'd love to help one of you all out
instead of just finding some random repo
somewhere so send me a message somewhere
on Twitter or something and I'm happy to
help
all right cool I thanks John John says
take care hope all goes well tomorrow
thank you I do too hopefully if any of
you are the praying type please play for
my wife she's having a lot of a lot of
health issues and we're trying to figure
out what's wrong so hopefully we'll have
some answers tomorrow it's my my button
to stop the stream okay have a great day
I'll be back on Wednesday